and her new friend give him the hand but  not your car keys David so no too bad  you started in Paris yes so where did  you study on Harvard Society for  Contemporary Art they looking for  artifacts they want to protect the  historic pieces subject is still  dreaming time to wake him up  what kind of weak ass man well at wallop  I thought you say he broke up with you  he did because I did the only thing a  red-blooded woman came to in that  situation forced an ultimatum you choose  me or you choose your family and  heritage and he chose three thousand  years of beautiful tradition didn't you  believe that there are no rules there's  no government no babysitters no dead  times no Crowley faces no bush mustaches  and no negativity of any kind you just  said the word no like a thousand times  and there's also no consistency I hate  this place any idea is a good idea  except the not happy ones those to push  down deep inside where you'll never ever